hey I'm Josh Wolf and I'm Jacob wolf and
this is family tussle the father-son
competition show where the loser has to
do an embarrassing punishment let's go
we're doing the orb competition where we
get in those giant inflatable balls and
our legs are sticking out the bottom and
we're running at each other and trying
to knock each other down bucket list
check I'm gonna try to get the glare of
my leg
mine off into his eyes and then knock
him over my strategy going into the
fight is a low center of gravity you
know I'm feeling pretty good I think
violence today are are not bad I'm not
faster I'm not quicker do not have the
stamina
I'm really not pumping myself up that
well
we're here this is the orb challenge
basically what we're gonna do we're
gonna get in these things and there's a
little box back there that we have
walled off
it's the best of three
or the best of five if I don't win the
first time and basically rules are you
get a point if you knock somebody
outside the line or you get them to the
ground now we have uh two expert judges
here to help us with our strategy and I
have chosen Brian Simpson and I have
chosen Jeremiah Walter Watkins that's
fine
really well
we're gonna do really well today we're
gonna do really well Watson
all right you guys ready are you ready
I'm ready all right let's go
whoa have you ever been inside anything
before
he'll know [ __ ] about leverage so low
and he's taller than you low man wins
how's your spin moves good I did I did
one yeah a little little B button yeah
should I name my moves
um yeah is it good to have a good name
you should not just name one but you
should save him while they're happening
like an anime great idea come on
they don't know what they're talking
about they have zero idea
yeah the tea bags that's a great one
would you got the knees for that no okay
[Applause]
we're Team Watson we can't lose
wrong one he wants blood come on come on
oh
[Music]
round two You Want Blood he's your blood
get it come on keep going keep going
keep going a couple more couple more
couple more
final round
oh wow oh don't get overzealous Jacob
ugh
[Music]
to the death to the death go
until somebody falls on the ground
that's the point that I want to see I
want none of this line crap
hey let's go let's go I already won
generation next [ __ ] he did knock me
out but I think the number we kept going
so I want you guys to confer yeah and
talk about it let me get out of the way
do you think that they should do a
sudden death first one to get to the
ground wins the whole thing that's what
they just did how about Jeremiah and I
[Music]
in a strange turn of events this bout
will be decided by sudden death
[Music]
manage your face off first take down
wins let's bounce
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
that's
[Music]
what I'm talking about
oh [ __ ]
dude I'm gonna get out of this 80
Seconds
that's for the Reagan Era [ __ ]
that's right how do you like that
we're the New England Patriots of this
competition
and we cheated a little bit I only
compete in things I'm good at this is
just requires you to be a fat piece of
[ __ ] that used to be in shape how did
Josh surprise you he surprised me by how
fast he got tired like you said let me
take off his shirt he got six pack and
all that but the old man six-pack ain't
the same I guess just kind of keeping
you to get keeping your schedule I think
it would have been much funnier if Josh
wasn't a good father there would have
been way more pent-up energy from Jacob
like you know they love each other and
this is for that Christmas that you
missed right Jacob wolf I do want to
tell you this
I'm so impressed thought it was going to
be so much stronger than you and I'm not
kidding like you having you've really
impressed me man I appreciate it I also
was a little bit impressed you had a
little bit of more agility out there
than I thought you were going to have as
well so hold on all right listen dude I
love you love you too and uh I guess
congratulations
what's what's the punishment gonna be
I can't wait
you know like a responsible father I've
always tried to
stress the importance of safe sex so
today I'm sending Jacob into CVS to buy
some condoms some very specific condoms
you shouldn't wear your small condoms
[Music]
um
like the Magnum but that says large I
don't know if that's gonna work for me
okay ask her if she thinks it's possible
to take the chapstick out and just use
that tube I mean do you think it's
possible if I just like if I get a
regular chapstick to just take the
chapstick out and use the two like do
you think that'll work or
I think or like do you guys have any
extra slips like you know the rolls of
pennies when you put pennies in a roll
do you have one that's like half that
size
no something like the size of a small
sandwich bag anything like that yeah I
mean you're talking to an old lady
foreign
[Music]